so the new netflix movie 1922 is based
off
a stephen king novella i love how the
intro the movie gets right to it we're
introduced to wilford james
who is writing a note in a hotel room
and he says he has a confession to make
and he tells the story of the crime he
committed with his son
murdering his wife so you realize right
from the start this is going to be a
movie with a little bit of narration
which i always get a little worried
about but i thought the narration in
this movie was
really well done because it wasn't too
much it wasn't over the top
it was just at the right moments with
really powerful quotes
from wilford james to get inside of his
head basically following that short and
sweet formula but what was funny to me
was the man narrating and our main
character wilford james the actor's name
is thomas jane who i'd recognized from
the show hung that used to be on hbo
if anyone's watch that show but that
show was pretty bad and he played a very
normal character so i didn't know what
acting chops he had it kind of worried
me
but he did great here he was spectacular
i was like wow this guy can act the guy
from hung
but what did get a little annoying and
it's not his fault was he did a
really good midwestern accent but when
translating it to film
it was really hard for me to hear and
understand totally what he was saying at
every scene
especially when he was talking to his
son like in the crop field and i was
like am i really gonna put subtitles on
right now and i did 10 minutes in i gave
up
i had to put subtitles on i could not
understand his lines clearly i don't
think i'd be able to enjoy this movie if
i didn't have subtitles on so if you're
in a situation where you couldn't put
them on you might be getting really
frustrated and if i was in that
situation i might have given this movie
a completely different review like he's
going full-on marbles in the mouth like
hey
oh you're going in dude bam bar bam
town in your moon like oh man
really tough i was reading a lot but i
don't mind that too much so we learned
that basically his wife wants to move to
the city
take the son with her he wants to stay
in nebraska
not lose the acres in his land
technically owned by his wife's family
he doesn't want to lose his son just
wants to keep everything the way it is
it's really interesting because it
delves into that stubborn ego a lot of
men have
especially his fathers and he talks
about his narration here in the movie
about how much
pride there is in a man's land i guess
in this area back in the day this was a
big thing
but he valued his home basically over
his wife and it wasn't all totally his
so it was very selfish
and i'm not giving the wife full pass
either because there was no attempt for
middle ground here you know maybe not go
fully to the city but maybe not stay
in the sticks maybe try to find a middle
suburban area i don't think that'd be
too crazy but that's not happening here
completely two opposing sides and then
when it comes to the sun it gets really
hairy because they both want him what
does the father set out to do
convince the son to murder his mother
which is crazy
and he uses every ploy of manipulation
on his son
starting with shannon the cute neighbor
next door that henry has a crush on dad
sees this
finds us his weak spot and brilliantly
manipulates his son saying hey if we
move she's gonna be gone this is all
gonna be gone our life's gonna be
terrible
but if we do we have to do everything's
gonna be peaceful we can move forward
now this is where the narration a movie
like this really works because
when he figures out in his head that
he's gonna use shannon we get to hear
that
and he goes every man is another man
inside of them and he had a conniving
man inside of him and he might want to
use this to his advantage there's almost
like a low case of multiple personality
disorder here where he can switch into
this monster and fully go in on it
and not really leave it during these
intense scenes with him thinking about
murdering his wife there was really
creepy violins playing which always
works in a hard type film and it worked
here especially in the narration where
he's like
is on man's time not gods classic
stephen king writing for you
every line has purpose here every line
has meaning but can you imagine if
you're in the sun henry's shoes your dad
is thinking about killing your mom and
then you're torn to even
help i wouldn't consider it ever ever
but the sun clearly is because he's in
it with just like his dad
and what was very sad was when wilford
straight up lies to the wife
and says they're gonna move and he's
cool with it and the sun's coming and
everyone's
happy and she's getting drunk and she's
kissing him
and it shows you too like hey wilfred
are you seeing right now
this is working and this is what will
happen if you say yes and maybe
put your pride away for a second realize
you're picking property
over loving family that didn't click in
his head and it was just his ploy to get
her murdered and get her drunk
before it actually happens though which
was important they had to show henry
kind of give a resistance right before
they do and he did and he suggested
lawyers and his dad again
master manipulator saying this is the
only way boy and that's a big quote here
because the sun keeps suggesting there's
gotta be another way there's gotta be
another way there always is another way
but his dad is so hell-bent on this that
in his head he's developed that this is
the only way
it's the only way i can get out of this
situation i don't wanna be in the scene
where he's murdering his wife
is brutal glad they didn't shy away here
it's very graphic
it's very bloody and i love that it was
like a struggle for the dad and the kid
did nothing to help he was terrible
look if you're gonna go through that you
had one job hold your mother down for
christ's sake commit to
it and he couldn't do it you had one job
henry and he just backed away so now he
just screwed up his conscience for
nothing which i thought was hysterical
and the dad was just bad it was such a
sloppy
throat coat which i liked seeing because
most gory scenes like this they're
always
somehow professional at it and it just
cuts right through the neck but this
showed you
a realistic way of how hard it is to
just kill somebody but then we see
the husband just chucks his wife down
the well which is ridiculous and then we
got that really cool shot when he looks
down the next day and there's rats
coming out of her and out of her mouth
that was really well done and staring
right at him which was awesome because
now it's like okay the haunting's
beginning
he's gonna start feeling this guilt now
she may be dead but she's in your head
and i'm laughing at that scene but then
when he throws a poor cow down the well
i feel terrible i'm like what'd the cow
ever do and then i'm being a youtuber
cause i just ate a burger a couple hours
ago before filming this maybe i should
take away something from this maybe i
should go vegan after this one i also
really like the lawyer here who came and
visited i wish we got more of him i
think maybe just because of his great
line where when he's referring it to
being hot in the truck that drove him
there
when he says my citaphone that would be
the same
i may have to start saying that
referring to my butt so then where it
got a little worrisome in the movie for
me was when shannon starts realizing
henry
is not the same and the father's trying
to convince her just like he's fine just
keep him encouraged
this is where it shifted the movie to me
where it got a little bit predictable
and very formulatic like seeing the
visions of his wife that he killed
trying to get his son to be hush-hush
rats following him everywhere it kind of
starts just to become something you've
seen and know for know what you think is
going to happen or at least what i
thought was going to happen
and then we see a great scene where the
sun talks back to his dad you couldn't
even slit
mom's throat right and he basically
threatens his son what good is if i have
no one to pass acres on to
just crazy then i really really like
this sequence though
with wilfred in the winter and i'm gonna
give the actor props because
i may have never seen someone play cold
as well as he did here i fully believed
he was out there freezing his butt off
and the whole sequence was great with
the winter storm it looked so well done
and real i felt like i was there
i almost started to feel bad for him
surprisingly which i didn't want to what
was good because it was making me think
a different way for a hot second so then
i got really stephen king horror like
when the wife comes down the steps
whispers in his ear all things he
doesn't want to hear and he's just
living through the worst possible thing
that can happen to his son now and he
admits he deserves it and he's like just
kill me i don't want to hear this like
i'd rather die but she's like no now
her revenge is not having him die so it
was all coming back around
but i was really not crazy about the
whole
henry and shannon becoming bandits a
little cheesy
really kind of a stretch he would just
start robbing everybody and she'd be
okay with the shannon it's kind of just
throwing all at you and it was a little
goofy
and their death scene was even a little
goofy the baby gets killed was kind of
just a quick way to get
everything to go downhill for the sun
but it felt disappointing in his ark in
a way i thought i want a little more
development or maybe he
grows up a little bit more we see that
it was kind of just happened right away
so for me it took down a huge element to
this story
and sure i know it's his purpose was to
make the father feel even worse
and now he's paying for it that his son
has died thought it was just
kind of hey your son is getting all the
worse things happen to him now
here you go screw you or i want some
resolution with the sun's
ideologies and how his mind was at the
end and that's why i thought they
wouldn't go forward with it again i did
not read the novella by stephen king but
not crazy about that turn of events did
cause a suicide note from the start
again
that was very predictable as well but i
really like at the end when he's
wrapping up his suicide note it goes
back to when mofo was talking to henry
one night and henry's like i'm afraid to
pray and he's like i hope there is no
god because
if there is no heaven then there's no
hell really really strong
writing here and they did it really well
in the movie so the rats all come to the
hotel room obviously they're
basically in fernie's about to kill
himself but when he sees
his wife his son and shanna come back to
him a little goofy because
some reason cgi here of their bodies
looked like
ps2 graphics playstation 2 for anyone
doesn't play video games and that was a
little disappointing because still a
netflix movie
at this point you got to put a little
more money into that if you're going to
do it
i don't know if i was even necessary
maybe just have all the rats coming in
and cave on him i don't know if he had
to see them one more time
especially shannon i felt a little weird
because i don't generally be cared about
her wasn't the most satisfying ending i
thought this movie started really well
but after the wife kind of got killed
and the recovery was good for a bit but
then you kind of get bored because it
just dragged on
and it's kind of note for know what you
think is going to happen again it's just
predictable something you haven't seen
before
really good acting though all around
that was the bright spot for me
and the narration worked really well
here you weren't confused and it was
still enjoyable but
it essentially comes down to just a
story about a man and a son
living with a terrible mistake they did
and the consequences they suffer not
the most entertaining concept so overall
i'm gonna give it a 7.5
good not great if you enjoy stephen king
stuff though and you enjoy
movie just to chill out you don't have
to really pay attention fully you can
kind of just get a good story
that old time feel in the country this
is the movie for you and if you want to
see a great great acting performance
you will get that from thomas jane i
will say he deserves award consideration
for this
if you like other stephen king made
netflix movies i also did a review of
gerald's game
check that out but the most important
thing to take out of this is subscribe
to steve varley you'll be happy you did
i do a bunch of movie reviews
tv reviews celebrity interviews as well
so please keep coming back and i'll see
you on my next video